hey 42 here a 2015 study ranked the
United Kingdom as the world leader in
soft power that's the ability to
influence other nations by whispering in
their ear the United States on the other
hand is the world leader in hard power
using their vast military might to beat
of a country's into submission put it
this way if the UK is petyr baelish then
America is the mountain the difference
in approaches between the two nations
foreign policies has a lot to do with
the way each country's government
functions the British government has
what's called a division of power in
which the Prime Minister is not a to the
country leader but is simply the head of
government as well as an adviser to Her
Majesty the Queen who mr. true head of
state the president of the United States
however is the one and only head of
state and executive leader over the
entire country and its people all this
basically means that in the u.s. a hell
of a lot of power is given to one person
apart from perhaps Putin there are few
heads of state that have more individual
power than the US president even Kim
jong-un has to share his power with his
deceased grandfather who is technically
still president but in reality how real
is the American president's power how
much power do they really possess will
Donald Trump be able to build a wall
without permission from Congress should
you be scared the President of the
United States or POTUS is effectively a
dictator as long as he or she sticks
within the confines of the law the POTUS
is free to do whatever they please
however if this power was pushed to its
limits the POTUS would face impeachment
they would have their presidency swiftly
removed so for this reason and to gain
the approval of the general public in
the hopes of winning a second term in
four years time presidents often behave
and do what the majority of the American
public wants them to do but if a
president weren't sound of mind and had
no morals
what could they theoretically do
well to start with an obvious one the
president is commander-in-chief of the
military and can do whatever they
pleased with its 1.5 million troops and
endless toys and that's not just a
troops at home the president has total
control of 800 military bases in 70
countries across the globe oh and let's
not forget the 7,000 nuclear warheads at
the president's disposal so what about a
bit closer to home what damage can the
president do to their own peoples since
they are in charge of powerful
organizations such as a CIA NSA and FBI
the president can find out whatever they
like about pretty much anyone and
enforce any punishments they so desire
in a heartbeat the president also
receives intelligence from numerous
allied countries lawmaking is a
different kettle of fish and is often
where most presidents come unstuck on
their path to power if the president
wishes to amend or create new laws they
have to create a bill which is passed
through Congress if it receives a
majority vote in Congress and the bill
is passed to the President to sign if he
signs its then the law simple right well
that's only if Congress is on the
president's side that's to say the
president's political party has more
seats in Congress than the opposition
party obviously if you have more friends
on your side then Congress is more
likely to vote in favor of any bills you
decide to pass and it just so happens
that when Donald Trump is inaugurated he
will have a majority number of
Republican seats in both chambers of
Congress the House of Representatives
and the Senate in fact the current
Congress is the largest Republican
majority since the 1930s and even if
Congress doesn't vote in favor of
Trump's fatuous plans for some reason
then he can always turn to an executive
order which is basically there so that
the president can turn his middle finger
up in Congress and do whatever the hell
he liked and
Congress can always pass legislation
that opposes the president's executive
order but the president is free to veto
anything that Congress passes so yeah I
think he would probably do that
if however a president's executive order
is in conflict with the Constitution it
can be taken to the Supreme Court who
have the power to either allow it or
quash it which historically would have
acted as a nice balance to stop the
president's power getting out of control
this next term however because some
Supreme justices are retiring soon and
other reasons Donald Trump will have the
rare opportunity to pick who he would
like to be part of the Supreme Court
giving him considerable leverage over
the most powerful court in the land he
may get to replace up to four of nine
justices and when you consider that the
average serving time of a Supreme Court
justice is 26 years who he picks now
will affect the country for generations
it goes about saying that anyone who
achieves the title of President of the
United States is inevitably going to
become one of the most powerful
individuals in the world Franklin D
Roosevelt is often Fortas of the most
powerful precedent in history he
certainly issued the most executive
orders by a mile but with
ever-increasing usage of executive
orders and a Republican majority at his
back some experts theorize that Donald
Trump will have more power at his
fingertips than any predecessor I'm
sorry if you aren't satisfied with this
answer if so you may want to look at
emigrating to any of these five
countries which statistically have the
most stable political systems in the
world I personally go for Denmark they
have unbelievable breakfast pastries but
that's just me thanks for watching a man
known simply as zeona has a grand total
of 39 wives and here's the head of the
world's largest family welcome to what
what the most densely populated place on
earth
kowloon walled city was home to over
33,000 people